yeah at 25. and then you get uh
recognized in africa
oh it was crucial which you're just like
won't it i couldn't believe it
dude yo i couldn't believe that that was
like
that was like the light of that whole
like trip like knowing people
know you in africa what they say to you
like i was eating and the girl came up
to me she was like oh my god you
you the boy from instagram i'm like wait
a minute i'm 16 and a half hours
over the water not even you know driving
on the other side like
what yeah this is crazy
you know that was like real inspiring
it's like
that's how like you know i know i'm
doing what i'm supposed to be doing like
when you connect with people
across the world it's that's that's it's
like
if you give up you giving up on so many
people it's like
dang like he don't do like you me you
make people days you inspire people
help others chase their dreams you know
help people find out what they love to
do and that's the beauty of it like
that's the purpose of
you know why i do what i do so yeah man
to actually inspire you
yeah it's not just about entertaining
because inspiring yeah inspiring people
man motivating people because
you know i do you know even though like
you said they don't see the
they just see the video they don't know
what we go through on the other side you
know this
the pressure that you own and how you
got to keep pushing through this stuff
to
keep feeding the people you know because
it's not about you it's really now it's
about the people now
it's crucial yeah listen to what they
want and give them more yeah man
so yeah i feel like
in the and you you're getting recognized
in africa and
shooting a film over there it's it just
seems like
there are no boundaries anymore in terms
of
entertainment and that's where tv
they're coming tv almost creates like a
box
and you get stuck within that box but
the internet
has it's it's infinite it's it's
infinite it is
it's beyond it's like it's you don't
have to wait
yes you don't have to wait anymore you
don't have to
like you can create your own short films
you can create your own movie because
it's okay i can't remember who i was
watching but
he was in the interview i can't think of
an actor name you know they was
talking about you know people say they
want to do you want to be an actor
or you you just want to act you know
and it you know like what do you want to
do okay you say you want to be a actor
okay
but create your own stuff then you'll be
active you know what i'm saying
you want the fame and you want to be on
that level because
it's like what do you want like what is
it that you want
you know what i'm saying like because if
you we can create a short family
we're acting but it's really the fame
it's really that big thing that people
are
chasing i think having clarity in your
goals is crucial
so you know where you're headed most
definitely some people are like oh i
wanna
i wanna go on instagram get a million
followers okay why
yeah what do you wanna do with them most
definitely you gotta have a plan you
gotta have a plan
yeah and once you find that that's
another thing once you find that plan
it's like everything will continue to
grow as well
yeah will you actually write down your
plans most definitely
you have to write the goals down i write
goals down
like it's like now like the platform
that i have on
the mindset i have the platform i have
on instagram is for
everything on the outside it's for
movies it's for tv it's for
the next level stuff it's for people to
come to my shows
you know it's now instagram is just a
platform for me
you know it's for my supporters i want i
want my supporters to to be inspired
of me going to the next level i want
them to see that man i i i gotta i want
to get to
another level just to show them how
how god worked you know and he can do it
if you believe but you got to believe he
can do it you know
and having goals i've heard people
almost they'll visualize them or they'll
write them down every day
or they will actually take time to write
down their goals
and then just let them almost let them
almost ferment
and come to life and you can physically
see them before they actually happen
most definitely because i don't written
out a a few goals that
that has once i focused on them it came
to pass
and it's it's like you really have to be
focused on what you you written i think
success is
focus is a big part of being successful
as well and knowing what
what it is that you really want to do
and once
you focus in on that
and you find purpose in that and you be
consistent into that
eventually you're gonna get what you
what you written down
eventually it's gonna come to pass you
know i'm very spiritual because you know
that god promised us these things you
know we really know
we okay this this the goal is really i
feel like you know it's just she forgot
but we still got to do our part as well
you know we just can't rely on god to do
everything you know people
pray to these things and they say all
right god we went on are you doing you
just sit back and just wait on god
no you got to put in your work you got
to
you got to you know once god see you
doing that that's when he going to
elevate you he's going to give you the
strength to like keep going
do you put timelines on your goals like
i want to know this by this
time i um like how i write in my goals i
do them yearly
so i i want to accomplish these things
this year
so i don't i don't know when it's going
to happen i just know in between this
year
these goals going to happen so what's
what's on
the goal list for 2018 uh one of my
biggest goals is to be on tv
yeah and how specifically though like
you want to be a tv show you want to be
on a talk show like
how do you do you help clear this goal
yeah family
is it yeah either a tv show or a movie
okay that's acting though yeah yeah
acting yeah
yeah is this your tv show or um
just tv however yeah however yeah i want
to
i want to be on tv 2018. that's the big
goal that's
my biggest goal right now okay that yeah
what i have
i have zero doubt my man is gonna happen
you've you've been such a thrill
to have on this show and it's it's
really been an honor to be able to
capture this moment in your career
yeah i appreciate it i know you're very
busy and the fact you're willing to sit
down
with the hot breath of earth oh yeah man
i enjoyed it man appreciate you
[Music]
before we get out of here man is there
anything else you want the world to know
um i would just say man hey find your
purpose in life man find out what it is
that you really want to do and
stay consistent with it and make sure it
brings a positive light
to the world thanks for watching hop
breath the verse if you want to support
the show
go join our patreon but if you don't
like supporting a comic on the hustle
at least click to watch more videos to
keep us alive in the algorithm